zone Europe sur sensation
bonsoir et bienvenue dans une Europe sur
Radio sensation et sur TV 78 pour une
émission spéciale enregistrée au
Parlement européen de Strasbourg
zone Europe l'invité politique
bonjour Marie-Pierre
française députés réunion au Parlement
européen également vice-présidente de la
Commission du commerce international
vous travaillez notamment pour lutter
contre eux la coercition économique
alors d'abord est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer de quoi il s'agit alors
la coercition économique en fait c'est
la volonté pour un état de tiers de
l'Union européenne d'imposer son
positionnement aux autres États je vous
donne un exemple concret ça peut
paraître un peu comme ça compliqué on
l'a vu dernièrement